let's think about how we can define
matrix addition and math mathematicians
could have chosen any of an arbitrary
number of ways to define addition but
they've picked a way to define addition
that seems one to make sense and it also
has nice properties that allow us to do
interesting things with matrices later
on so if you were one of these
mathematicians who are first defining
how matrices should be added how would
you define adding this first matrix over
here to the second one
well the most common sense thing that
might have jumped out at you especially
because these two matrices have the same
dimensions this is a two by three matrix
has two rows and three columns this is
also a two by three matrix two rows and
three columns is to just add the
corresponding entries and if that was
your
intuition then you had the same
intuition as the as the mathematical
mainstream that the addition of matrices
should literally just be adding the
corresponding entries so in this
situation we add
one plus five to get the corresponding
entry in the sum which is six
you can add
negative seven plus zero to get negative
seven
you can add
five plus three to get 8
you can add and i'm running out of
colors here you could add 0 plus 11 to
get 11
you can add 3 to negative 1 to get 2
and you could add and you could add
negative 10
plus 7 to get negative 3. and if you see
this definition of matrix addition you
see that it actually does not matter in
what order that we actually add these
matrices i could have done this the
other way around if i did this the other
way around let me copy and paste this so
if i were to add this matrix
so let me copy and let me paste it
if i were to add it this way that matrix
to
let me copy and paste the other one to
this matrix
so copy
and paste
if i were to go this way you'll see that
the order in which i'm adding the
matrices does not matter so this is just
like adding numbers a plus b is the same
thing as b plus a what we'll see is that
this won't be true for every matrix
operation that we study in particular
this will not be true for matrix
multiplication but if you add these two
things using the definition we just came
up with adding corresponding terms
you'll get the exact same result up here
we added one plus five and we got six
here we'll add five plus one and we'll
get six we get the same result because
one plus five is the same thing as five
plus one here we had zero plus negative
7 you get negative 7. so you're going to
get the exact same thing as we got up
here so when you're adding matrices if
you were to call if you were to call
this matrix right over here matrix a
which we normally denote with a capital
bolded letter and you call this matrix
right over here matrix b
then we take the sum of a plus b which
is this thing right over here and we see
it's the exact same thing as b
as b
plus
as matrix b plus
matrix a
now let me ask you an interesting
question what if i wanted to subtract
matrices so let's once again think about
matrices that have the same dimensions
so
let's say i'm going to do have two two
by two matrices so let's say it's zero
one three two
and from that i want to subtract
negative one
negative one three
zero
and five
so you might say well maybe we just
subtract corresponding entries and that
indeed is how you can define matrix
subtraction in fact you don't even have
to define matrix subtraction you can let
this fall out of what we did with scalar
multiplication and matrix addition we
could view the same this as the exact
same thing as taking zero one
three two and two that we add negative
one
negative one times negative one three
zero five
and if you work out the math you're
going to get the exact same result as
just subtracting the corresponding terms
so this is going to be
what is this going to be
0 minus negative 1 is positive 1 1 minus
three is negative two three minus zero
is three
two minus five is negative three and
you'll see that you get the exact same
thing over here when you multiply
negative one times a negative one you
get a positive one positive one plus
zero is 1. negative 1 times 3 is
negative 3 plus 1 is negative 2.
fair enough there might be a question
that is lingering in your brain now okay
sal i understand when i'm at adding or
subtracting matrices with the same
dimensions i just add or subtract the
corresponding terms but what happens
when i have matrices with different
dimensions so for example what about the
scenario where i want to add the matrix
one zero three five zero
to the matrix so this is a 3 by 2 matrix
and i want to add it to let's say a 2 by
a 2 by 2 matrix 5
7 negative 1 0.
what would we define this as
well it turns out that the mathematical
mainstream does not define this this is
undefined
this is undefined so we do not define
matrix addition or matrix subtraction
when the matrices have different
dimensions there didn't seem to be any
reasonable way to do this that would
actually be useful and logically
consistent in some nice way